das wort
sehr geehrter präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren in der tat wir
reden offenbar durch die fraktion in
sechs von verschiedenen dingen heute
morgen deswegen möchte ich meine zwei
minuten nutzen um noch einmal klarheit
zu schaffen warum in der tat die frage
warum oehring eckert nicht so sehr eine
frage des individuellen falles ist es
gab auch keine frage von fußballspielen
sondern eine frage des rechtsstaats und
der fähigkeit zwischen individuell
entscheidung zwischen moral und recht zu
differenzieren wir sind hier der
gesetzgeber und wir haben darüber zu
entscheiden was für dieses land gut und
richtig ist und wenn die vergangenen
jahren asyl und zuwanderung permanent
verwechselt wurden wenn sie ganz bewusst
auch häufig nicht differenzieren wollten
wollten verzeihung zwischen flüchtlingen
und einigen ableitungen daraus zwischen
asylbewerbern und zwischen illegalen
migranten dann ist es höchste zeit dies
endlich zu tun und den bürgern darüber
reinen wein einzuschenken dass das
parlament die regierung in den
vergangenen jahren gerade dieser
differenzierung einfach versagt haben
und dass dieses versagen ein ende haben
muss
insofern kann de maizière bundesminister
ist es richtig dass wir hier dringend
eine begrenzung des familiennachzugs
brauchen konsequent wäre wenn sie nicht
nur den kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner mit
der spd finden müssten sondern merkten
dass es in diesem hohen hause eine ganze
reihe von abgeordneten gibt die in der
serie konsequenteren regel zustimmen
würden aber dies bedeutete
prämisse über parteigrenzen hinweg und
wir alle wissen wie schwierig das ist
insofern werde auch ich dem antrag der
union unter strafe zu stellen weil ich
eine aussetzung ist zum 31
siebten führt zu wenig heute aber sie
ist besser als nichts im sinne der
bürger im sinne des rechtsstaates und
hoffentlich im sinne einer zukünftige
regelung die endliche differenziert
zwischen einer notwendigen geregelten
einwanderung und dem was ein gnadenrecht
des staates werden sollte das asylrecht
dankeschön
diese debatte ist der kollege stefan
meyer von der cdu/csu